while dark souls is best known for its
fantastic gameplay intricate level
design with interconnecting paths and of
course
its challenge the game also has
incredibly deep lore allure is so deep
that the pitch of my voice does it
absolutely no justice and you'll need
avadi vidya to explain it to you
but while many lore scholars including
myself look it up i have years worth of
videos diving into the subject have
looked into every little detail of the
lore both with wild theories and
speculations as well as grounded solid
research there's still some elements of
the game that have completely evaded us
like where are the top halves of the
dragon but demons in izalith how did
their upper torsos melt off when it's
their feet that are in the lava if neato
has sentience and has the death lord's
soul isn't he technically undead like
so join me as we go over some of dark
souls greatest mysteries some of which
we've solved and some of which still
elude us to this day
who is gwyn's firstborn son
within the flames four beings found four
different lord souls that granted them
unimaginable power the witch of izalith
the life soul nido the death soul the
furtive pygmy the dark soul and gwyn the
light soul
gwyn nido and the witch of izalith
fought together against the reigning
dragons to take control of the land
fighting alongside gwyn was his
firstborn whose name was essentially
removed from the annals of history and
his deific status was rescinded on top
of that all statues of him were removed
so all honor and mention of him would be
lost to time
and as such it was a much debated
mystery as to who this son was what he
did to deserve this punishment and if he
was even in dark souls 1. before we
proceed this mystery contains spoilers
from dark souls 3. so if you want to
skip on to the next one click on the
timestamp below my face
and now on my face
thanks editor the first possibility was
everyone's favorite blacksmith and all
around badass andre of astora according
to an interview for the dark souls
design works with hitake miyazaki
miyazaki stated that andre vestora was
originally a descendant of gwyn whose
task was to protect a door within the
firelink shrine in the end he was going
to push aside the goddess statue to let
the players progress but as development
progressed he became just a simple
blacksmith
but you can't take cut content to be
canonical
unless it's a lore theory that really
really needs it in which case don't
worry about it and i would never
ever do that
the second possibility and one of the
most popular theories was that it was
soleir of astora you might be seeing a
theme with a story here and if andre was
originally supposed to be gwyn's
firstborn and he's from astora maybe
there's some significance there solaire
is a self-proclaimed adherent of the
lord of sunlight as an undead he's come
to the birthplace of lord gwyn to find
his very own son
so the theory goes that he was estranged
from gwyn for some reason however still
worshipped his father and came to
lordran to find his own son which of
course also represents gwyn the lord of
light after all gwyndolin had to even
create a fake sun to portray that gwyn
is still in power within the land of
anor londo
finally the most compelling evidence of
all according to the ring of the sun's
firstborn lord gwyn's firstborn
inherited the sunlight and if you join
solaire's covenant as a shining member
of the warriors of sunlight you'll
notice how intrinsically linked to gwyn
and the worship of him it is the statue
of this covenant is destroyed making it
likely it's a statue of the firstborn
for joining you'll receive lightning
spear and at rank 1 great lightning
spear you can even offer gwyn's soul to
receive sunlight spear in other words
for joining the sun bros you'll gain the
ability to use gwyn's zeus like attacks
all of this led to heavy speculation
that soleir was gwyn's son and this
covenant a way he was trying to atone
for his sins
but killing soleir isn't considered a
betrayal to the covenant
so
maybe the crazed sun obsessed looney is
just a member as gwyn is tied to the sun
and sunlight so at the end of the day it
was a compelling argument but there were
also enough holes in the theory that
people weren't ever quite sure i mean
why would gwyn's son who's likely a
completely different race from that of
the furtive pygmy become undead in the
first place and it's always been my
opinion that if there's a hole in the
theory then it's a sinking boat and as
it turns out this one we can say is
solved thanks to dark souls 3 we can now
confirm that gwyn's first born son isn't
andre vestora or even soleir it is in
fact the newly introduced nameless king
the nameless king who can be found at
archdragon peak arrives in fashion
riding atop a storm drake and his stolen
item descriptions act as a tell-all the
nameless king was once a dragon slaying
god of war before he sacrificed
everything to ally himself with the
ancient dragons
that's not unlike gwyn's firstborn son
who was a god of war his dragon slayer's
swordspear was imbued with lightning of
which the nameless king was the heir and
of course gwyn's firstborn would have
been the heir to lightning
so once upon a time the nameless king
fought alongside gwyn in the great
battle of the ancients where gwyn nido
and the witch of izalith vied for
control over the lands he was so
successful at this he was clearly dubbed
a god of war however at some point the
nameless king tamed a storm drake and
this bond eventually led to him
switching sides similar to seath and
betraying his own thus while seath
gained rewards betraying the dragons
gwen stripped all honor and mention of
the nameless king for his betraying of
gwyn
so we can deem this mystery of gwyn's
son
solved
next up one of my favorite mysteries
what is the pendant for
at the beginning of the game you'll be
allowed to choose one starting gift to
take with your character the most
practical and in my opinion fun of these
is the master key as this will open up
multiple paths in the game without
needing their normal keys opening up the
number of routes you can take right off
the bat the most interesting is the old
witches ring as it will allow you to
talk with the fair lady meanwhile black
firebombs are fun as you can quickly and
easily kill the asylum demon at the
start of the game without needing to run
away and therefore get his drop the
demon's great hammer
but one that has puzzled souls veterans
for years is
the pendant
in an interview with fumitsu the game's
director hidataki miyazaki suggested
that when choosing a starting gift he'd
pick the pendant or nothing at all
but here's the pendant's description
trinket no effect but fond memories
comfort travelers
surely there has to be more to it than
that right
dark souls is filled with secrets so
there has to be something the pendant
can do
or at least that's what many gamers
thought and hoped and i still hope
beyond all hope one thing you can do
with the pendant is trade it to snugly
the crow for a souvenir reprisal
and
that's it players scoured the game for
every possible way the pendant could be
used but to no avail
so was this just miyazaki trolling
everyone or is there some deeper secret
to it and as much as i would love to say
there's some secret thing the pendant
does
no one has found it yet in a later
interview with ign hidetaka miyazaki
stated when it comes to the pendant i
actually had a little bit of an
intention to play a prank considering
that at this point the game has been
completely data mined and people like
lance mcdonald have shared that with all
of us
well i think we'd know by now if it did
anything and unfortunately
it doesn't outside of snugly i mean but
that one doesn't matter sorry snugly
sadly the pendant is also solved
onwards to the best location of the game
what is the skull at ash lake ash lake
is my favorite area of dark souls to
discover it you need to find and go
through not one but two illusory walls
is incredibly well hidden probably
thanks to gwyndolin
who i believe created all of the luxury
walls in the game
just saying and it appears to be a relic
of the age of ancients before the lords
took over back when the grey stone
dragons ruled it's also incredibly
reminiscent of nausicaa and the valley
of the wind which i'm totally okay with
ash lake raises so many questions for
example to get to ash lake you have to
traverse down a giant hollowed out arch
tree the great hollow
and when you arrive all you see around
you are endless arch trees so is the
entire world built on top of these arch
trees is this the foundation of all of
the land as we know it
interestingly ashley can be seen in the
distance within the tomb of giants
there isn't much in ash lake except for
the stone dragon man-eater shells and a
mushroom parrot in basilisks which
probably made their way over from the
great hollow and of course a hydra which
unlike the previous hydra can also leap
but one oddity we can find in ash lake
is this giant skull the skull is unlike
anything else we've seen in the game it
doesn't resemble the nearby hydra nor
does it resemble any other enemy or npc
so what skull is it
given this is ash lake and it appears
similar to where the battle amongst
archeries of the intro cutscene took
place a dragon skull seems like a
reasonable deduction
but as the skull doesn't have an
elongated snout that kinda rules out a
dragon some have speculated this could
be the skull of a giant as some believe
that it resembles some of the skulls in
the tomb of giants i don't personally
see it and while it's still a viable
theory it's not one i can personally
stand by
but at the end of the day we really
don't know and it's a prominent set
piece of ash lake which is what makes it
all that much more of a major mystery
following up a guessing game we've all
pondered at
who is the narrator
who the narrator is is a question that
has evaded us since the dawn of dark
souls and we never really received an
answer of course it's possible this is
just a generic narrator to explain the
story without any real character but
that doesn't mean people haven't
speculated that the narrator is someone
important and that's why they know so
much about dark souls story given the
narrator's voice this really narrows
things down to being an older woman of
some sort the witch of izalith is a
centipede bug monster guinevere seems to
be too young to have this raspy of a
voice at least in the illusion that
gwyndolin created to portray her it
certainly isn't quelana because we know
what she sounds like the narrator is
voiced by peaksen lim and she does no
other voices within the game so who
could it be
okay so there's this theory that it
could be velka why velka is the goddess
of sin she is a rogue deity but versed
in arts both new and old and is
considered to have a great range of
influence even as gods are concerned
so that fits with the idea of someone
who would know enough to give us the
player all of the backstory but let's
talk about crows for a moment within the
painted world of ariamis crows and half
human crow hybrids are seen looking over
and guarding various items related to
velka in fact within the design works
miyazaki is quoted saying the crow
demons were originally designed as
worshipers of the goddess of elka whose
bodies were warped by their devotion i
think this obsession makes them really
interesting characters
remember how i said cut content doesn't
count unless i say it counts
it counts here but that's really because
there's plenty of in-game evidence to
support that the crows are related to
velka the crow demons happen to carry
souvenirs of reprisal which are directly
related to the book of the guilty
maintained by velka so now that you know
all about crows let's look back at the
intro cut scenes in the second cut scene
where we hear the narrator speak it's
none other than a giant crow who takes
the chosen undead to lordran so if the
crow who carries the chosen undead from
the undead asylum the lordran isn't all
likelihood related to velka does that
mean the narrator is also related to or
possibly velka herself
well
no that would be a pretty huge logic
leap at this point it's possible but
there really isn't any direct evidence
so at the end of the day we really have
no idea who the narrator is or if it's
even supposed to be some character from
the game making this mystery
unsolved
so those were just some of darcel's
greatest mysteries this is a new show
idea for us so if you liked it or not
let us know and if you'd like to see
another episode dedicated to dark souls
what are some mysteries you'd like to
see covered or other games let us know
in the comments below and hopefully i'll
see you guys in another mystery video
[Music]
you